make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys are the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so getting into batman/superman
number one like the story of this Shazam
whoo laughs this is a really really cool
story because this fits in nicely with
Scout Snyder's Dark Knight's medal know
with Williamson I don't really worry
about making sure things fit into
continuity but there are riders where
you do kind of worry about that right
for those of you guys who were finishing
Superman unity saga the witch will
actually do the second video or yes the
first part of the conclusion
we'll do that today as well yeah Brian
Michael Bendis just kind of the inks out
an ending out of nowhere and it's we're
part of anything out of nowhere and it's
like it's the day is saved and it's kind
of like okay you know but with William
so I never really worried about that
with a lot of writers when they do
tie-ins where they do like a follow up
to an event ah they'll in turn like
start crafting a story and change things
almost like they're they're generally
aware of the original story but never
actually read it and that's one of the
things that I was the you know that that
that there is pause to be concerned for
it but again with William soon we don't
really worry about those kinds of things
right I mean the guy's an outstanding
writer the guy keeps everything in
continuity I definitely dig his work and
so what this does is it initially takes
place in the dark multiverse itself and
it picks up basically with Superman now
for Superman is summoned to the Justice
League Watchtower basically by Batman
and again this works really really well
because when it comes to Batman of
Superman they're kind of the one-two
punch of the comic book community right
I mean and when I say come on Wikimedia
I mean like in general including Marvel
DC like valiant the whole nine yards
like they are the one-two punch in so
far is like they're the two guys right
ladies are the two guys that you always
call when Batman is Superman team-up
then you usually get spectacular stories
out of it because it's brain and brawn
and so when this takes place and when
Superman blight actually gets out there
he gets into the watchtower only to find
that basically everybody's been killed
this is a cool thing is because if you
remember during the Batman who last
one-shot comic the tie-in to Dark
Knight's metal that gave us his origin
story this is what he did right we don't
really know exactly how he did it
we just know he did that he went through
and essentially like he like killed all
the members of the Justice League right
so like like Hawkman Hawkgirl and then
you have like Martian Manhunter and
you've got Wonder Woman and and flashed
everybody like they're all literally
just dead and when Superman had walked
into the watchtower because of the fact
that the whole place had been flooded
with a kryptonite gasped he was
immediately dying right like he was
immediately the end of him like like
this whole place is flooded with
kryptonite gas there's no way for you to
get out of here you're going to die so
it was kind of a precursor to everything
right because we know that following
this little this little bit of an
introduction that in turn what he'd done
is he had kidnapped Jonathan Kent and
Lois Lane and
brought them to the watchtower and then
infected both Jonathan Kent and Superman
with black kryptonite which of course
drove them insane and they tore Lois
Lane apart and so it's kind of
interesting because this was really done
to incapacitate Superman it didn't
really lead to his immediate death but
like it was designed to incapacitate
Superman and then turn him into his dark
herself by using black kryptonite and
the whole reason why the Batman who
lasted this was because he was kind of
like oh just curious I was just curious
what you would be like if you were like
your darker self again it's really
twisted and it's really more screwed up
but what this does is it jumps to earth
zero now this is where the main story
basically begins to pick up and what you
have here is is Commissioner Gordon
summoning Batman himself now when he
summons him Batman also does sort of
kind of talks right and Commissioner
Gordon thinks he's talking to him but
Batman is basically running over
everything that had happened since the
events of Dark Knight's medal that after
that story where it seemed like all the
Dark Knights had basically been defeated
the Batman who laughs survived and then
kind of started going through with this
campaign to try to make Batman into his
darker self to kind of present this idea
that Batman could only ever be happy if
he basically gave in to his darker side
right so very similar to The Killing
Joke right the Joker's desire to show it
all it takes is one bad day for a person
to snap and become just like him now of
course it hadn't worked for Batman he
ended up staying and and becoming a good
guy you know I guess staying a good guy
and staying his normal self as we saw
during the the the was the Batman who
last parts 1 through 7 full story but
basically he's running over all this and
explaining it all to Superman and that's
kind of a funny thing here is because
you would expect that Superman would
know all of this right I mean we know it
at the end of the Batman who lost that
he's basically stuck in the basement of
the Hall of Justice and he's being held
prisoner there but just because he's
there doesn't mean the suit that Batman
explained everything to Superman and it
could be the Batman just took him there
and threw him in right because any
member of the Justice League can access
the Hall of Justice right I mean they're
part and parcel to the team they can
come and go as they please and so it's a
cool little bit of a thing here because
basically all this stuff that sort of
explained to to Superman insofar as like
the danger of an alternate reality
version where there's a Batman who has
all this intelligence and all the
Joker's insanity and can use that to
achieve whatever goal he wants now the
meat-and-potatoes for why it is that
that commissioner gordon's summoned
Batman here and and really Superman by
extension is because there's a little
kid named Danny miles that's gone
missing right he's been missing for a
little while his parents are freaking
out and it's pay Batman like we needed
we needed you know to be sorted out and
Batman's summoned Superman here to base
they talk to him in to help him with
this case now one of the cool things
about this is that this is actually the
first time in the history of really
since 352 that Superman has met Jim
Gordon is a pretty awesome little moment
to go on here
not as messing around somebody somewhere
out there somebody is furiously typing
away on their keyboard like freaking
Ellen not true I found something Rob is
wrong about yeah like it's it's it's
interesting there's nobody losing it
right now but the whole reason why
Superman was summoned here by Batman is
because this is kind of Williamson
touching on Tower of Babel and it's cool
right he doesn't explicitly say it and
even in the aftermath of tower Babel
while it wasn't referenced all the time
like the stage had basically been set
this idea that Batman had protocols to
take out each member of the Justice
League if they lost their mind and they
went rogue and that's kind of what
Williamson hits on right like Batman
literally asked Superman
do you have protocols on what would
happen if I became evil like if I'd lost
my mind and decided to take everybody
out are there any protocols they're like
do you have any way to make sure that I
wouldn't use anything against you and
it's kind of a funny thing because at
the outset you would think well yeah I
mean Superman's protocol is to just
punch Batman's head off right I mean
just like it's like mr. Sunday movie
said like all the way Superman could
kill Batman right like like do this
thing and then kick his head off like or
punch his head off or like rip his head
off or something like that like all the
different ways to pull that off where's
Ashley a pretty amazing video you guys
should all go watch that but the fact
remains it's Batman sort of asking the
question what are you guys going to do
if a time comes when with all my
knowledge and all my understanding of
your weaknesses and your strengths I
basically go crazy and I decided to take
all of you got all of you guys out and
the response to Superman really seems to
be we don't have one because we trust
you and that's cool and everything but
you always need to make sure that you
have apparently like a plan right like
it ruins the Justice League have to have
that because you're talking about people
who are exceedingly powerful or capable
in their own right Batman's not really
powerful he doesn't really possess any
powers but between his intellect and and
all his knowledge on the members of the
Justice League he could bring them down
quick fast and in a hurry that was the
nature of Tower of Babel right like all
these different protocols that were set
up to incapacitate each member of the
league in case they went awry or or
whatever the case was for a Superman to
kind of respond like that almost really
seems naive like one of the most
intelligent member of your superhero
team and indeed probably one of the most
intelligent members of the of like the
planet Earth short of maybe Lex Luthor
basically awarded
into a villain with all its knowledge
about you you have no safeguard for that
like you have no way to protect yourself
from that that's how the Batman who
laughs won presumably is because his
whole league trusted him and there's
something to be said about trusting him
there's also something to be saying
about being foolish about not really
taking the steps you need to in order to
make sure that you and yours are safe
right because more important than any
individual in the Justice League is
safeguarding the earth itself and
ensuring the league's survival that
supersedes everything right so you kind
of have to make sure all that is set in
stone now when this happens of course
they end up travelling down with a
scrape a huge hole where where it seems
as though Danny miles has basically gone
to or at least where it seems like a
place where he would have been taken and
when they get there of course there's
all these mech BOTS essentially that
were brought in here by the Batman who
laughs and they're all taken out pretty
easily what this does is this leads into
essentially like this big makeshift
place where the Batman who last was
operating out of and it's not really
even makeshift I mean it's built and
designed pretty well but were the Batman
who lasts and the grim night were
functioning that's what this is and this
is a cool thing because we never really
saw the tried and true lair of the
Batman who lost we never really saw the
tried and true lair of where he worked
out of we know he did we saw a little
glimpses here in there but it's cool to
essentially see the whole thing right
it's cool to see like this entire thing
in terms of where he was functioning and
what he was doing but like all these
difference you don't like like battering
malls all these different things all
these devices were designed for the
purpose of having essentially remnants
of the map Batman who lost serum as well
as things like green kryptonite to take
out Superman and so it's obvious the
plan of the Batman who lost was much
grander than simply just incapacitating
Batman it would have put two queens in
the chessboard no pun intended because
what you would have had is a Batman who
laughs who has all the all the
intelligence of Batman and all the
insanity of the Joker who in turn brings
the main DC Universe Batman over to his
side you've got to evil Batman running
around a universe they would decimate
all everybody would fall fall prey to
them and so what this does is it almost
leaps to a kind of game right there's
this chess board that's basically set up
between the white in the black side and
the way the pieces are arranged no side
can move without the other winning right
so like if the black side moves a piece
white wins if white moves a piece black
wins right just because of the way the
chess set is set up and so as a result
of this it's kind of like well what if
we move a piece like let's just see what
happens and when they do it ends up
basically bringing this giant image of
all the different members of the
superhero community when I say all I
mean all of them every single member of
the superhero community
and the idea is they're all they've all
basically been joke arised meaning
they're all a target for the Batman who
laughs syrup right for the video to
basically turn them all into villains
and so it's kind of cool because when
that happens suddenly the two of them
are met by the you by one of the crows
of the Batman who laughs now these crows
were always ambiguous and really it
wasn't even like Scott Snyder never
really even gave us in the indication of
what they were you know when this story
was initially announced it was funny
because I saw people who were
complaining about the fact that like Y Z
Y is you know Joshua Williamson changing
these crows to be what they are to make
them into his own thing but that's funny
like Snyder never told us what they were
the fan base assumed what they were and
then took that assumption as fact as it
was it's interesting right because I
mean we do that all the time but it's
it's sort of it's sort of intriguing
there so the result is that we basically
have this this crow who you know of
course a tax batman and then basically
starts talking to the two of them and
saying that like that man who laughs
took this this kid from his family and
and basically hit him with a Batarang
that turned him into the person that he
is now turned him into a crow and that
he changed this kid into what he is
forced him to start wearing this this
costume and basically like you know used
him in the various missions that he had
and so where you have Superman who
addresses this kid as as Danny miles the
kid says you don't understand I'm not
Danny miles like he took me like that
many laughs took me from where I was and
freed me like I'm not upset about where
I am I'm not sad about the you where I
and I don't want to go back home like
I'm free like like do you guys not
recognize me my name is Billy Batson and
so this is crazy because what we get is
the Shazam whoo laughs and this is
awesome because Billy in turn shouts the
word Shazam and then basically like
becomes this insane powerhouse and ask
the question I always wondered what it
would be like to beat the crap out of
Superman and actually what he's got in
his hand is to stab him with one of the
one of the Batman who laughs batteries
this is amazing because like the notion
of a Shazam whoo laughs right I mean you
know sue ran whoo laughs would be cool
but Shazam is a fan favorite you guys
love him and so let you take like Shazam
and then you turn him into basically
like a bad man who lost character oh
it's beast it's amazing
okay so we're picking up with Batman
Superman number two which god I've been
dying for this comic to come out because
like the first one was so good it was
due to his amazing I was like what a way
to intro it like what a way to bring
this in like this Shazam who last now
here's the cool thing and I think this
is actually gonna prove to be one of the
most important parts of this particular
story arc fit that Joshua Williamson is
writing initially you pick up with
Commissioner Gordon right outside of
Gotham City in the Gotham City Police
Department Armory so while it is in the
GCPD armory it isn't usually normal for
him to like kind of sneak off and meet
with somebody outside the city for a
particular purpose right in the fact
that it is the armory means that of
course it's police property meaning
Commissioner Gordon could go in there
and basically dismiss everybody
temporarily or find a place to meet in
secret and basically talk to this person
who really appears to be Catwoman more
so than anything else but he basically
talks about the various forms of
evidence and all the poisons and all the
things that the various villains from
Gotham City used that is all basically
locked down by Wayne tech security right
so this seems to indicate that he's
talking about the Batcave or someplace
basically controlled by Bruce Wayne we
could argue like Arkham Asylum but it
would make sense for for Commissioner
Gordon to be able to just go into Arkham
but there is also a lot of red tape
right I mean Commissioner Gordon isn't
really like the warden of Arkham so he
couldn't just walk in there and take
what he wants he would need a warrant in
order to be able to access that
information
it looks like he's talking to Catwoman
because he's basically saying like not
even Commissioner Gordon has access to
these things it's impossible to get past
except for this one particular person
and the reason why I say Catwoman is
because she's like the greatest thief in
all of Gotham City right and I would
probably say probably the world I mean I
don't think that DC's really broken down
the level of thieves in terms of how
they compared to everybody else but
nonetheless at this point it transitions
to the actual fight between Shazam
Superman and Batman and this I think is
really what you guys came to see the
fight between Shazam Batman and Superman
now this is the reason why this works so
well is because on the surface if you're
not really knowledgeable about like the
weaknesses of Superman on the surface
you would look at this and just kind of
see a boil down to a fight between a
Superman esque character and Superman
but it's far more interesting than that
because remember Superman has a weakness
to magic and that's one of the things
that's one of the the I guess the upper
hands this Shazam always sort of had on
him now she's not a straight-up magic
wielder like you know like like cetana
or somebody like that but magic is
invoked in the powers that he uses and
so it's kind of cool to see Joshua
Williamson sort of tug on that little
string and then having
face off against Supes and so with
Batman being part of the phrase it's
sort of funny here because it's just
sort of like the Batman just a guy at a
Halloween costume right like Shazam who
laughs doesn't really take him seriously
and indeed there's no reason for him to
and so with that being said like you
basically end up having like the the
question of Batman of where's this thing
being kept of course she's essentially
on the hunt for something and it's a
cool scenario because when is it
happening as Superman goes to uses heat
vision on Shazam and the Shazam turns
back into Billy Batson and this is
genius here this is absolutely genius
here's reason why Shazam I always sort
of saw depicted as a young naive kid who
was an answer to the question what if a
teenager had the powers of Superman
that's really how I always saw him and
for the most part that's really what he
was like what if you woke up one day and
you had all of Superman's powers but you
had them on command I want to be
Superman now and you basically got all
those powers that that that the Man of
Steel has what would you do with that I
never saw him as the sharpest tool in
the shed I never saw him as very good at
like trickery and deception or anything
like that and mostly because of the fact
of the way he's been written over the
years isn't really exactly like Superman
it's more so that he has other people
who were smarter than him to basically
kind of help him in aid him right so you
got like the wizard Shazam who can go to
for guidance who in more recent years
you have the Shazam family he even
learns lessons from my black Adam who's
exceedingly old and has a lot of like
battle-hardened wisdom to sort of in
part on Shazam albeit by Beebe the craft
Adam
so the fact remains that there are a lot
of teachers in the world of Billy Batson
and so I never really saw him as a kid
that doesn't really that there needs to
learn more than how to like defeat this
particular foe or to use his brain in
some smaller fashion what he does here
is genius because he tricks the heck out
of Superman
he's just like Jude Superman I'm sorry
man I don't know what's going on I get
these weird visions and nightmares and
things like that you gotta find a way to
help me and it's just like messing
around got Superman to lower his guard
and then turns back into Bill it turns
it back into Shazam again right like
this is genius and this is one of the
coolest things about bringing in
characters from the dark multiverse is
it gives us iterations of the characters
that we don't normally see that while
Billy Batson is by no means an idiot
he's certainly not like super good at
like tricking people and and using like
espionage and subterfuge to get what it
is that he wants but doing that here is
really really really smart like it's
pretty awesome and so what he ends up
doing it's basically sort of kind of
revealing to Superman a bit of his
intention now in reality
she had to be taken with a grain of salt
and the reason why I say that is because
what he does is basically saying that
like hey you know you always considered
my existence to be a joke you guys laugh
at me and you guys talk about me behind
my back different things like that
basically like you never really took me
seriously you had me on the team because
I'm powerful but not really because I'm
addict and the reality is that this is
not Billy Batson from the main DC
Universe this is Billy Batson for the
dark multiverse and so what he's
basically doing is bringing all those
ideologies from the dark multiverse into
the main DC Universe and then basically
putting them onto Superman right like
projecting them onto Superman and saying
like how you guys existed in my universe
is how you guys exist here which is not
necessarily true but what it does do is
allow him to maintain this fantasy of
believing what he wants to believe and
so it's a really cool concept it's a
really cool idea it's a great reflection
of people in the modern day and so of
course then you have that man who just
comes flying in with like the Batman who
laughs up battling because remember when
the Batman who last came over from the
dark multiverse the first thing was
being part of Dark Knight's medal but
following the defeat of Barbados then it
turned into well how can I basically
bring down this earth and turn it into
like a dark multiverse version of itself
and so it wasn't really enough to say
hey like we're gonna start injecting
people with toxins he basically had to
have systems in place they could make
him comfortable to Batman and with
Batman having all these gadgets and
things like that the Batman who lost had
to have his own version of those and so
that's why you saw the Batman who lives
having things like like his own batwing
and insulin and so forth it was a way to
just kind of build as his presence up
and that to allow himself to become a
legitimate danger to Bruce Wayne because
at the end of the day why would Bruce
Wayne be worried about himself running
around on earth who doesn't have a bat
wing or a Batmobile or a bat boat or a
bat credit card like why would he have
to worry about that guy he's just like
okay so like I'll just track him down
and then shoot him in the face when he's
like running away from me and that would
basically be it but it's kind of a cool
thing because what Batman does is
basically roll up on Shazam and then in
turn like Stabbin right now what it does
is it allows show Sam to essentially
like incapacitate Batman to send him
flying down to the ground while he's
unconscious and force Superman into a
choice do you want to defeat me or do
you want to save Batman and now here's
kind of a funny thing and in reality I
would have said I would have defeated
his am like I want to know what would
you guys have done would you guys have
defeated Shazam
or would you have saved Batman like I'm
kind of curious it's like a video game
choice right like what was it uh Arkham
City
we're like you're Catwoman and you have
to choose between like taking the money
and leaving or like saving Batman
i livestream that at one point and all
you guys like a bunch of you guys were
watching and I was like what
should I do you guys were like let
Batman die you guys are heartless you're
terrible people terrible people is what
you are but uh but but nonetheless it's
really cool here because I would have
defeated Shazam and the reason why is
because Batman you know Bruce Wayne is
very very capable that's true and really
like Dick Grayson and and and Tim Drake
and Damian Wayne and Jason Todd if you
chose to
and even Batgirl like they're not really
a battle right they're not a perfect
stand-in but hey they're good enough so
I would have been like alright you know
hey sorry Batman it's been real it's
been good but it ain't been real good
cuz you're kind of a dick so like I'm
gonna defeat his am Shazam's gotta go
and then like just go to Dick Grayson to
say man it was it was terrible man like
it was awful you know it's you know it
was a tough choice to make man but like
you won't be Batman though like this
basically how it would go that's
basically how that whole situation would
go down and it is kind of funny because
in turn when Batman wakes up in the
fortress of solitude he actually starts
chastising Superman and just being like
why didn't you stop Shazam why didn't
you let me die and indeed it would have
been the smarter move to make now of
course Superman ends up doing the
Superman thing worse like when I looked
into his eyes and I saw that it's really
Billy Batson he's just struggling with a
few things and it's like look we're not
talking about drug addiction right like
we're not talking about you know Shazam
you know that the Billy batts he got his
heart broken by some girl he met in like
the ninth grade and and like he didn't
he was never in love before and he
couldn't get over it and he was just
struggling forever he decided the best
way to do it was become some angsty
teenager who's also an evil version of
Superman more or less well that's not
what we're talking about like we're
talking about a legitimately evil
superhero out there who's who would
further the plan of the Batman who lasts
and turning the entirety of the world
upside down so it's it's kind of crazy
because in doing this and it's sort of
taunting of Superman
what Shazam basically revealed to him is
that the Batman who laughs is working
with basically dark multiverse versions
of themselves right so like the Superman
who laughs and the Wonder Woman who lost
and the Aquaman who laughs of different
things like that what it does is it
provides them with an N and this is kind
of the benefit of Superman and it's why
he did what he did right because it's
kind of like okay look we could defeat
Shazam who last but at the end of the
day we're treating a symptom we're not
treating the cause we need to actually
treat the cause right so let the small
fish go to catch the big fish that's the
cool thing that goes on here and so we
were basically he sits down and analyzes
these batarangs that were used by the
Batman who lasts and each one is
basically encoded to the particular DNA
sequence of each member
of the Justice League and designed to
infect them in a way that will basically
allow complete and total control right
so Superman being a being being weak to
kryptonite the battering was laced with
some form of kryptonite
most likely in order to basically pierce
the body of Superman and then in turn
infect him the question is where do we
go from here
and that's when Batman and Superman
formed this plan what they end up doing
is basically traveling out and the Oh
Batman says like no one can know what
we're doing here this has to say secret
now this is really the question that I
had is without with a scenario like this
like a Shazam who lasts running around
out there you know how does a Justice
League not get involved and is basically
Batman telling Superman like no one can
know what we're doing this has to be a
secret mission between the two of us no
one can be aware of what's going on and
then he asked the question are you truly
ready for this and the response of
Superman is one I always knew that you
had the Batman whoo laughs being held
underneath the Hall of Justice because
I'm a journalist you know now in reality
it could have also been like I just use
x-ray vision because I was bored one day
and I wanted to see if anything need to
be cleaned and then I just saw the
Batman who last is under there and I was
like what in the heck is going on like
at me do it that would be kind of cool
that would've been pretty interesting
too but uh but nonetheless Superman
figured it out very very fast and he
basically says it's the only real option
that we have and so this is what's
really cool here is because suddenly you
switch over to the Batman who lasts and
when that happens like in comes Superman
as the Superman who lost and the Batman
who lost greets him as an old friend
which is crazy because here's the
question I have is this actually the
Superman like like Superman who's fine
and pertaining to be the Batman who
lasts or is it Superman who is who is
like the Superman who lasts right like
is that really what's going on I imagine
it's probably him faking it but it'd be
awesome if it wasn't this entire time it
was actually the Superman who laughs who
was pretending and like Billy Batson
transforming into the normal version of
himself is Joshua williamson's Way of
telling us that that would be awesome
okay
so we are eating back into Batman's
Superman like we're getting back into
that man Superman in the last video we
basically ended that on like Superman
busting into the prison book beneath the
Hall of Justice or the Batman who lost
is being held and then in turn like
breaking him out right and so the big
question is this this is kind of the
question that we ended this on you know
is it is it Superman full uninfected or
is it Superman working on behalf of
Batman and the circumstances lent
themselves to the idea the Superman was
working with that
and this was all just one great big ruse
and and that's really what it turns out
to be right I really just turned out to
be a circumstance where Superman
infected himself with the Joker toxin in
order to go underground or I guess in
order to infiltrate and to trick the
Batman who last into believing that he
has successfully been infected and so
basically like this prison break or at
least the Oh breaking amount of this
facility is one of the worst-case
scenarios in a lot of ways because what
it means is the Batman who lasts is on
the loose again but the other half of
this and the reason why this is so
interesting is because a Superman
playing a dangerous game now is one of
these things where Superman is kind of
like okay so like we couldn't get the
plan for Billy Batson like like you know
what's what's his plan like what's the
scheme that you have and the way the
Batman who laughs does this is it's kind
of hilarious right because I was reading
through this and I was like this is like
one of the most grandiose schemes in the
history of everything right like it be
it's kind of an insane scheme but at the
same time it sounds like it would be
nothing the Batman who laughs would do
because what he says here is like my
scheme I my grand plan here is to infect
all the superheroes of your world and
then like infect everybody in your
multiverse and then like destroy your
multiverse and it's just kind of like
really that's your that's your grand
scheme like this your grand plan as to
what everything out of existence and he
actually ends up going as far as to
might on Superman and be like you know
like your mom felt when your world
exploded that's how you're gonna feel
it's almost like he's touring with the
Man of Steel and the reason why is
because as soon as Superman basically
reveals a fact that he's not fully
turned right he lets his temper get the
better of him and starts tearing into
the the Batman who lasts ultimately
Batman jumps in with kryptonite and
stops Superman and that's when you find
out they never broke out right like they
never broke out of the facility like
they've they've been in there the entire
time they're super and just walked in
there so this perception that like the
Batman who last had been broken out this
belief that like he was on the loose
again that none of it was real but
here's the funny thing about this is the
Batman who laughs knew it's kind of this
revelations like hey he knows what's
going on right like that's why he's
taunting you that's why he's toying with
you that's why he's using you is because
like he knows that all this is a ruse
but he knows that all this is a trick
and so he leaves them one last clue you
know when they ask him like who are the
secret six that you infected as if it's
gonna do anything is if it's going to
like help at all you know it's going to
help with anything they end up asking
him like you know who who are the secret
sticks that you infected Anthony lashes
like I'm not gonna tell you guys who it
is I got going to reveal all the names
uh uh I'll just tell you like I wouldn't
shine their name in the sky with a light
you know and right off the bat Batman
immediately figures out who this person
is right so drops
man in this giant facility where it'll
basically bombard him with solar
radiation and it'll help to essentially
you know get rid of the Joker toxin now
here's the thing about that right like
the more I say the more I think about it
this way here's the thing about that if
if joke I'm sorry if Superman was
infected with the toxin of the Joker
from the the DC Universe right not even
the men him in Batman who last the main
DC Universe and he was cured of it it
would stand to reason to following that
Batman would use his intellect to figure
out how to adopt a faster cure to find a
way to basically cleanse the Joker toxin
from Superman as fast as possible plus
you know yellow sunlight you know no I
guess it really I mean the only other
alternative besides that it's just like
put Superman and the capsule will shoot
him into the Sun ah the problem is you
know I mean he kind of needs them and so
basically racing over to Gotham City
this is one of the things I like about
this because Williamson does not ignore
some of the stuff that happened in the
Batman who lost right like that's one of
the things that you guys will see when
it comes to two different crossovers
those are guys who are new to comics and
people who have been around in comics
for a long time will tell you this is
true and it is the bane of almost any
comic book fans existence right like
it's the one thing we hate the most like
is is it's the one thing that people are
pissed off not with Brian Michael Bendis
which rightfully so cuz Menace is right
he's Superman the basically ignored
everything that was done or you know in
actually comics ended and Superman
before him which kind of sucks because
it was some amazing storyteller like
fans were pissed but but still you know
like it's one of those things where
writers will come along and they'll
ignore the work before them they'll
ignore the previous work and then like
fans will kind of feel like they're left
hanging right because they're kind of
they're part of this like cohesive story
and then suddenly it just gets cut off
it pisses us off to no end to be honest
it is really what it is but but this
basically picks up after the events or
at least it really ties in to the
conclusion of the Batman who lasts
because what we saw is the end of that
story is that the person who was
infected was Commissioner Gordon and
that Commissioner Gordon was in fact the
first person in the main DC Universe to
be infected by the Batman who laughs
right like I mean I guess aside from
Batman himself you know following
following that my Commissioner Gordon
was the first one to be infected and
he's been infected the entire time and
you end up learning the whole thing was
a ruse right when he was like that a
Superman come help some kids been
kidnapped and you know that none of that
was real that it was all basically just
like this big scheme there was part of
the big scheme that was thought of by
the Batman who laughs in order to put
Batman a Superman one to work together
to give them to isolate themselves and
three like to basically infect Billy
bats
and so it's it's solid insofar as
Commissioner Gordon is is probably a
person that you wouldn't expect now the
big question to ask here is why was
Commissioner who weren't infected like
of all the people to infect why
Commission reporting because what can he
do right I mean he can like like what
keep Commissioner Gordon do in this
scenario that could really change the
game right they could really put things
in a circumstance where it was somehow
like changed the landscape right like
why Commission report because he's
basically just a guy who's a cop the
cool thing about this comes in the form
of Superman who basically says the bat I
knew last just wanted to prove he could
infect your closest friend that he could
get to that you could get to the people
closest to you but here's to see here's
kind of the issue with that like here's
the issue that I have with that and I
don't mean for this is turning like a
great big huge criticism of the Batman
of Batman to Superman by uh by no means
like I love this story to death but
here's the here's one of the things that
kind of strikes me as strange about that
is that was basically already
established that like the Joker the
Batman who lasts can hit you closest to
home right now that was a whole idea
behind the entire Batman who lasts
miniseries like there's no safe place
right like if he wants to come to you or
the people you care about he will right
so that's already established it may
just be one of those things where
Williamson is kind of establishing that
for people who never read the Batman who
laughs miniseries which I don't know why
you wouldn't it's an amazing miniseries
but like anybody who didn't read that
kind of bring that in uh but what it
does do is it basically says that like
the individuals who were being infected
by the Batman you laughs it's being done
for strategic purpose right so I don't
think it's simply just because of the
fact that this Commissioner Gordon and
he's a really good friend of Batman I
think there's other reasons behind this
I think there's a there's a bigger
motivation behind this in terms of why
Commissioner Gordon was infected here
now here's the other cool thing that
kind of comes out of this is you end up
having like one of these mech suits it
comes to sitting down on to on to Batman
and Superman Superman uses frost breath
and freezes it now somebody here correct
me if I'm wrong I'm a very lumpy but
somebody clipped me if I'm wrong we
haven't seen Superman uses frost breath
for quite some time right I wouldn't go
as far as to make the statement and say
that it that like he hasn't done it like
in the entirety of new 52 or DC rebirth
I'm not gonna make that statement I mean
I'm honestly I can't remember that far
back but I feel like we haven't seen him
do it over the course of rebirth I mean
it's it's it's kind of cool to see to be
honest with you guys like it's cool to
see him use as Frost with I don't know
maybe use it recently I'm not I'm not
100% sure I don't remember him using it
during venice's unity saga I don't
remember seeing him do it before minutes
took over on Batman or Superman
I remember seeing him do that like I
don't recall that it just kind of a cool
little small thing to see Jim Gordon's
taken out pretty pretty quickly why he's
taken out twice swiftly and that was the
expectation because what this does is it
forces Batman to think differently you
know his response here is okay if the
Batman who laughs thinks like me then
it's time for me to stop thinking like
me and it's time for me to stop thinking
like him right because it creates a
circular pattern if Batman sits down and
says okay so the Batman who laughs is
basically me I'm gonna think like him
which is thinking like me which is
thinking like him it creates a circular
pattern where he never gets out of it so
it's like let's nip that in the bud
let's think like what Superman would do
what would this Superman do he's like
like what would he do in this
circumstance and it's really kind of
cool to see because what it is is it's
Batman basically deferring to Superman's
logic is Batman deferring to him and
saying okay like one we're gonna take
Commissioner Gordon to the fortress of
solitude where nobody else can get in
here right where everything else will be
fine
and then like we'll go with what
Superman would do here because it's the
Batman who lasts not the Superman who
lasts right so it's kind of a cool thing
the problem with this is that
Commissioner Gordon was a Trojan horse
that's exactly what Commissioner Gordon
was Commissioner Gordon was designed to
was was basically he was that's the
reason why he's here is because he knew
that that that Batman wouldn't kill him
right the Batman he last knew that Bruce
Wayne would not kill Commissioner Gordon
he's gotta take Commissioner Gordon to a
place where he believes the Batman who
laughs can't get to him which would be
the fortress of solitude right because
the only people who can get in there are
people who are explicitly given access
by Superman right you can't just have
any swinging dick walking up to the
forces of Solitude it's being like Open
Sesame
and then like it opens up and they walk
in otherwise what would be the for me
the parties are calling it a fortress
it'd just be like you know a giant place
in solitude is what it would be called
like you know a relatively well hidden
location in in solitude gotta be what
you would have to call it uh the idea
here is that would that be in the case
of the Batman who last knowing that and
knowing Bruce would make that move that
leads to him bring Commissioner Gordon
to to the fortress of solitude which in
turn basically brings out Jaime Reyes
now here's the thing all right here's
your's the interesting thing about this
I feel like Jaime Reyes fans are
probably gonna like hit the roof and be
insanely happy
and rightfully so right because here's
here's the thing about Jaime Reyes Jaime
Reyes I think was really really cool
after Infinite Crisis basically when he
popped up you know when he became like
the new the new Blue Beetle he was
really cool as part of that whole story
the issue with Jaime Reyes is I feel
like in recent years he's kind of
gotten the rebuff right it's just kind
of like he's a guy who's there they
should watch a guy's piece like that's
basically it when it comes to heavy
writers like you don't really get much
with him you know the like DC hasn't
really pushed him all that hard and the
cool thing about this is that having him
being brought in as a person who's
infected by the Batman who lasts what it
does is really kind of williamson's way
of saying hey look guys you guys have
been sleeping on Jaime Reyes like that's
really what's been going on here right
and in reality people are like people
don't really understand how powerful
Jaime Reyes can be at a post Infinite
Crisis there were multiple circumstances
where was kinda like hey look if this
guy pushed his powers to the limit right
like it's him in the scarab push the
powers to the limit and basically take
all this tech and all this energy that
makes up what what it is that Blue
Beetle can do and then like push it to
an absolute peak they got would be an
absolute powerhouse in in DC Comics and
there are times that he has been so but
the fact remains that at the moment
right now like because of the nature of
the Blue Beetle suit because it's
basically a high-tech suit that's used
by by Jaime Reyes by virtue of the
Scarab this grafted to his back he could
infiltrate virtually anything and being
able to like putting him in a
circumstance where he basically becomes
this kind of you know work where
Commissioner Gordon acts as a Trojan
horse which allows Jaime Reyes to
basically like infiltrate the the tech
systems of the fortress of solitude and
then take them all over to essentially
take over Kryptonian technology makes
them like this hugely dangerous foe
because now it's basically like Jaime
Reyes amped up with with with like
Kryptonian technology that has to face
off against Batman versus Superman and
the guys totally insane at the same time
that's kind of the crazy thing because
what this does this is one of the weird
this is one of the crazy things about
this is that what this does looking at
the depiction of the suit as it shows up
at the end of this it doesn't really
look like it's Jaime Reyes in control
the reason why I say that is in DC
Comics one of the things that they
established is that this scarab can
actually seize control and totally take
over absent Jaime Reyes his influence
right so it's so it almost becomes this
kind of Bruce Banner incredible whole
thing right you know we're like The
Incredible Hulk takes over a Bruce
Banner can't really stop him
ah it's it's similar to that not
identical but it's something akin to
that but the Scarab basically takes over
and becomes like it literally grows in
size it becomes bigger it gets like
these spikes and all this crazy stuff
looking on his back that's kind of how
it looks at the moment you know now
again this is probably one of those
circumstances where this form is
achieved by the two of them working in
tandem because they both been infected
right I mean affected with a joker toxin
because of the fact that the Scarab is
grafted to this
of Jaime Reyes you infect one you infect
the other righty you can't really get
away with only infecting one of them and
then the other ones just kind of there
as a result of that Batman is - men are
taken out quick fast and in a hurry but
being able to infiltrate Kryptonian
technology in turn allows Jaime Reyes to
infiltrate the rest of the world's
technology right to infiltrate the Hall
of Heroes and all that kind of stuff and
this is this is one of the cool things
that goes on here is because what this
does is it ties into villains of the
year it's highs into Scott Snyder's
Justice League because those you guys
who are watching scott Snyder's Justice
League you have Lex Luthor who's
basically the apex predator now like
this you could call him a human if you
want to the way that he was originally
created when the multiverse was first
formed before it was wiped away and then
replaced with everything we've basically
been seeing since like you know the
formation of DC Comics in the modern era
as a result of that like he's he's he's
up he's basically like a Martian
Manhunter and a human being merged into
one is really what it is right that's
how people originally work but he's also
leading his Legion of Doom and the
Legion of Doom is one of these things
were it's kind of like trying to seize
control like ensure the survival of
Perpetua and so what this means what
this shows and so the Batman who lasts
is on a collision course with Lex
Luthor's forces here's the question I
have is the enemy of my enemy my friend
that's my question that I'm asking here
is because if that's the case then what
I would love to see come out and this is
even if it's only for a temporary
alliance right like Batman Superman the
Batman who laughs in the secret six
working together against the forces of
Lex Luthor
that would be legit like that would do
that would be faller cuz I do you
imagine like here's the thing imagine
what would happen if the Batman and the
Batman who laughs teamed up with each
other like imagine what that would look
like like nobody would stand a chance
they'd be like super Batman basically it
it'd be super Batman just wreaking havoc
on whoever he fights it'd be pretty cool
it'd be pretty solid
okay so we're picking back up again with
Batman versus not really Batman versus
Superman Batman Superman essentially
like the Batman who lasts now this is
awesome right because in the last video
we picked up with with Jaime Reyes
basically being infected and then using
the Blue Beetle scarab to essentially
infect a fortress of solitude right and
so what this does is follow up
immediately after that now for the most
part taking over the entire defense
system of the fortress of solitude and
using it against most both Batman and
Superman for the most part let Superman
understanding how it works
initially he would begin to find a way
out right like that was kind of the
expectation is that he would find
Way Out up Batman will be a little more
stuck right because he doesn't really
know the fortress inside and out the way
the Superman does but of course given
his ingenuity he would ultimately find a
way out as well and so really if it's
just Jaime Reyes facing off against
Batman versus a Batman of Superman
eventually they would be able to
overtake it right just by sheer force of
will or or what-have-you but notice this
the Batman who lost knowing what he
knows about Superman right and knowing
the Superman would keep an eye on him
and you know not really literally
insofar as listening to him and making
sure that he's not really making an
escape or something like that the Batman
who laughs uses this to his advantage
and just starts whispering in the ear of
Superman the funny thing about this is
that what you end up getting here is the
intervention of Donna Troy and Hawkman
but not in the way that you expect
instead they're siding with the Batman
who last and this is a crazy thing
because it's it's it's it's interesting
in this scenario because it's best we
could tell this is actually Donna Troy
from the main DC Universe right and the
reason why is because what she says of
course kind of lashing out of Superman
saying for everything you've done right
this is for Wally this is for dick this
is for Roy this is heroes in crisis
stuff and this is one of the reasons why
stories like that real why we covered
that I cover those events is because
it's one of those kind of stories where
yes it could be read in isolation but
also because it would be referenced with
regards to things that go on in the
future and that's exactly what's
happening here no one really knows what
was going on with Wally West when it
comes to Dick Grayson he was shot in the
head by KGB stright recovered the story
of a Batman fighting KGB so the reason
why that happened but Dick Grayson
changes name to Rick and he's basically
trying to live a normal life and
ultimately suffered like brain damage
and like memory loss and things like
that so he's essentially out and Roy
Harper died during heroes in crisis and
so because of the various escapades and
because of the various actions of Batman
and Superman over the years what are
they intended to do good things or not
it's resulted in casualties and one of
the things that Donna Troy hits on here
is that the the rule they play right
Superman being this this figure of Hope
and Batman being this Dark Knight that
while they are inspiring in their own
way they inspire people who are
essentially ill-equipped to become
superheroes to join their cause and then
March off to their dooms right but we'll
talk more about Hogman here in a second
because what seems to be going on with
him it's not actually what's going on
with him and it's actually a really cool
reference that joshua winston is pulling
out here but again like what we end up
learning here with Commissioner Gordon
really sort of you know speaking to
these guys is that everything that's
been going on here is simply one piece
of a much bigger puzzle and we didn't
really know what that puzzle was until
just now
that what he basically says is like you
know when Superman strolling down
Detroit like Batman who laughs is gonna
wipe out everything on earth the
response of Commissioner Gordon is well
it's just a purge is what it is it's
getting rid of the weak and only keeping
those who want to see the truth right
who want to have their eyes opened and
so what he basically says is that like
what he needed was an object from the
dark multiverse what he needed is what
used to be the Justice League satellite
from the dark multiverse of the Batman
who lasts and what are you done here
this is one of the coolest things ever
why the Batman who last had done here is
he had modified the satellite of the
Justice League from his universe that
were we can largely assume it functioned
in the same capacity as the satellite in
the main DC Universe right insofar as
it's a place of monitoring and it's
basically a place to kind of ensure the
things that are going on in the world
can be kept track of not in the sense of
the Justice League's spying on anybody
but in the sense that like if there's
different crises taking place around the
world they can respond effectively right
kind of a safety monitoring device yeah
what the Batman who laughs have done is
he had modified it in such a way using a
combination of various metals you know
in metal different things like that
that what it does is it essentially can
transform an entire planet right it
could infect an entire world that's the
idea is to bring it here and infect the
entirety of Earth all at one time the
issue was that they needed various
people to open the poor light to get the
the portal to a place where it could be
open and this is one of the cool things
about this because it sounds like he'll
you have these seven characters that
have exist these have been these
different things right so you've got
magic or just covered by uh by Shazam
you've got different characters have
played different roles here and it even
references back to the events of Dark
Knights metal it's like the first step
to getting this portal open was to
basically used Superman to get someone
to cross over to the other side to the
Dark multiverse which is exactly what
Superman did right when Batman was
captured by Barbados that Superman in
the various superheroes used the Tower
of the anti-monitor and the Phantom Zone
projector to get Superman over to the
dark multiverse that was the first part
of opening the portal right and it's
like all these little steps that have
taken place along the way that seemed
innocuous it seemed kind of like a thing
that was a good idea in the moment that
you never really thought anything about
suddenly become stupendously important
and it and it's awesome because what is
up happening here is of course Batman
kind of chimes in and says yes I do plan
for everything I'm Batman
of course I plan for everything which
includes somebody's stealing
Commissioner Gordon's old Batman honor
which again is a reference to the new 52
to DC you when when Commissioner Gordon
became Batman after her Bruce Wayne's
supposed death during Batman in the game
right so like all
these themes that have taken place over
DC in the last how many years this is
awesome I love this kind of feeling of
cohesiveness right I love these
references these callbacks to these old
stories it's a really really cool thing
and so of course Batman has to been
basically engineered their escape you
know but Batman detonating this this
Batman armor the Commissioner Gordon
used to use and then threw of them sort
of getting out there and saying okay
what do we do next
and so what Superman reveals here is
that as part of the fortress of solitude
this makes perfect sense right because
one of the questions is always asked
here is what would happen if somebody
like Lex Luthor infiltrated the fortress
of solitude and try to plunder all of
its secrets and soo-man basically
reveals that within the fortress of
solitude is a kind of reactor about a
core reactor and that if something
happens if things go south in the
fortress
you know things basically begin to go
awry then what can happen is is if the
accurate if the reactor itself is ever
in a point of danger then essentially a
release in danger of detonating that
every that everything will basically
lock down in the fortress and the
fortress will sink to the bottom of the
ocean right so nobody gets in and nobody
gets out and that's their idea here
their idea here is okay the the infected
individuals for the most part as they
exist here are locked within the
fortress of solitude so what we
basically do is we initiate a count now
we initiate a a protocol whereby the
entire fortress gets locked down and
basically comes down here we defeat
everybody who's here we stim the
infection and then when we're done we
basically you know initiate the failsafe
that allows the fortress to come back up
and we basically save the day
it's a super smart idea because what
happens here is is one of the funny
things that goes on is the question is
okay like Batman can you handle your own
against Donna Troy right because we're
gonna have to front face against these
guys can you handle your own against
Donna Troy and it's kind of funny
because you know Superman's like have
you ever sparred with Wonder Woman and
Batman's like yeah man we sparred and I
had bruises for months and I know she
was holding back it's cool
like it is I love that little thing it's
kind of a cool thing because then what
you do is you pick up with heart Hawkman
and you pick up with Donna Troy this is
one of the coolest things that data that
Williamson and DC have done is that this
is not actually Hawkman from the main DC
Universe
this is Hawkman from Earth three right
from the from the world of the crime
syndicate of America it's cool to see
that some of those guys are still around
I mean not as so far as the ones that
came over during forever evil from the
new 52 but like that's still a universe
that's there there's still various
super-powered beings that are there it's
cool to see that there's there's still
some ties being maintained there because
I love the concept of our three but
Batman showing up here to face off
against Carter Hall as well as face off
against Donna Troy it's kind of a cool
because Carter Hall makes references
like there's no Batman on my earth there
was only an alum and Batman it's like
yeah man I crushed him to write just
like I'm gonna destroy you and it's kind
of a cool thing because in the middle of
all this right where this conflict kind
of playing out the way it is it's really
even two on one in so far as Donna Troy
facing off against like Batman and ER
I'm sorry Batman facing off against
Donna Troy and Hawkman is a pretty huge
task even for Batman then suddenly you
have Supergirl who comes in to the
rescue right Supergirl is basically like
I overheard what was going on with the
fortress of solitude so on and so forth
and I'm here for this right now there is
a tie-in there of not really a tie-in I
guess it is kind of a tie-in in the
Supergirl series we can cover if you
guys want to see it but it's basically
Supergirl the infected and it covers
like what's going on with her and how
she got here and different things like
that but the idea here is is it's kind
of cool because in the midst of all that
you have a force Batman being rescued by
Supergirl and then in turn like it's
this attempt to basically you know for
Superman to speak with Jaime Reyes and
this is a very very important thing
right because ever since Jaime Reyes
took over the Blue Beetle from Ted Kord
right even before the events of
Flashpoint back during like Infinite
Crisis so on and so forth when Ted Kord
died when you had Tommy ray is becoming
the new Blue Beetle in a lot of ways
highly-rated was kind of rejected across
the board right by like a lot of fans
who looked at him and was just like he's
not Ted Kord though so I don't care
right I mean that's kind of book fans we
don't like it when things change right
it's just kind of the nature of us as
fans it's always been that way and and
the results of that is in a lot of ways
Jaime Reyes was initially rejected was
initially rebuked by by blue Blue Beetle
fans at the same time he was a character
that didn't really know how his scarab
worked he didn't really know how his
powers worked and so I wouldn't go as
far as to say he was looked at as a
liability by the Justice League he
certainly wasn't looked at on the same
level as Ted Kord and so in a lot of
legions is kind of like what's this
guy's place in the entirety of the DC
Universe what's the point of Jaime Reyes
as Blue Beetle and it's kind of been
this thing that's been holding over his
head for eons right it's just it's
always kind of been that way and so it's
an interesting scenario because the
response to Superman is we don't just
see you as a weapon you're a member of
the team you remember the Justice League
right you know if we've ever done
anything that led you to believe that
wasn't the case then I'm sorry about
that it was never our intention to do
that and so it's it's cool because it's
kind of like hey look man like you're
not as alpha as far out there and left
out the cold as you believe you aren't
but remember the nature of the infection
of the Batman who lost is to twist your
perspective of the wall right to twist
it inside out it's like having anxiety
right anxiety and depression it's too
twisted
sideout screw up your perspective so
that nothing that you see is actually
the way that it is and then in turn send
you forward out into the world and so
it's kind of interesting because in the
middle of all that the concentration
kind of breaks right you have Donna Troy
who shows up out of nowhere basically
ends up subduing Superman which breaks
the kind of connection he had with Jaime
Reyes Jaime Reyes reverts back into a
scarab form when the infection takes
hold again at least over the suit anyway
uh and then in turn you have like this
batter annual is the Superman Batarang
that's thrown and is designed here
Superman only for Supergirl to jump in
the way and catch it and this is a crazy
thing because it's one of these
scenarios where if you were if you're
looking at the story like if you're
reading each each thing as opposed to
skimming then like you would know
exactly what's gonna happen because one
of the things Commissioner Gordon said
was when he had the Superman other
Superman Batarang he said this was
specifically designed to pierce that
Kryptonian skin of yours and so
essentially what happened when Supergirl
caught it is it pierced her skin and an
infected Supergirl Supergirl is now
infected with the Shazam who last toxin
in addition to that you have the arrival
of Shazam you have the arrival of all
these various infected heroes who show
up I just want to say here right because
one you've got John Constantine who's an
infected member of the Batman who last
family right he's he's one of the secret
six I prefer to think of it as like the
Justice League who laughs which is
basically what it is it's like their own
little version of the Justice League
but you've literally got Shazam Hawkman
John Constantine you've got Donna Troy
you've got Blue Beetle and you've got
Supergirl
Supergirl looks amazing dude let her do
her design like when she's when she's
infected it looks awesome man like it
looks really really good
I think it's one of the coolest but like
the coolest depictions of a character
right because cheetahs looks wicked
right she almost looks like a
combination between like crush which is
the the daughter I think the daughter of
Lobo and like the Joker
right it's a really cool concept and I
really love the way that it looks but
yes essentially the secret six is now
formed this satellite is brought in
through the portal because the secret
sticks deform and open the satellite and
basically the batman who laughs is in a
position to infect the entire world
okay we are getting back into Super Girl
infected which is to say super girl who
is infected like the super girl who
laughs versus Batman in Superman this is
kind of nuts but first things first
I do wanna let you guys know that we
have been dumping a whole lot of full
stories recently like making like mega
full stories and everything's like that
we did a whole bunch of full story
videos with the individual story arcs
from Green Lantern but I want to start
ramping up and covering Green Lantern
again so what we're gonna do here is in
the next couple days we're gonna take
all the full stories we've done and
combine them into like a mega full story
the people on patreon already have it
they got it a few days early but uh it's
basically going to be like this nine
hour Green Lantern video it's the
longest full story video we've done I'm
curious to see how people respond to
nine hours like what I want to do I want
to max out the Youtube upload write the
most you can upload to YouTube is 128
gigabytes I'm gonna see if we can do
that like I want to see if we can if we
can like exceed that I feel like I
didn't being like a 15 hour long video
but I'm curious if you guys are gonna
watch nine hours of Green Lantern it's
kind of nuts right like that's an insane
amount of content but uh but yeah so
getting into this in the last video we
basically talked about how the Supergirl
uh you have Supergirl herself had
actually intercepted a Batarang that was
meant for Superman to turn him into the
Superman who lost and the result was
that she was infected instead this is
kind of cool right because this feels a
lot I don't know maybe you guys remember
this far back but it feels a lot like
the like like the Red Lanterns Supergirl
and and DC does that right you know a
little bit of exposition here a little
bit of explanation DC does that with
Supergirl um Kara zor-el is one of these
characters where she's been popular but
only under certain circumstances right
the original run of her character was
incredibly popular right like the
original Supergirl who when he was a
backup feature in the Action Comics
stories and then eventually got her own
solo feature in the adventure comic
stories she was really really popular
right but that was all before crisis on
Infinite Earths the issue was that after
crisis happened a Superman went back to
being the status quo of the last
survivor of Krypton right and he
couldn't be the last survivor of Krypton
like the last Son of Krypton if there
was like another Kryptonian out there so
they ended up kind of getting like this
weird other dimensional version some
kind of shape-shifting manifesting thing
that basically became the new Supergirl
it wasn't really the same and then
eventually Kara zor-el returned when DC
was like whatever just bring her back
who cares and fans that fans enjoyed it
but it's one of these things where like
people don't really read her stories all
the time but if it's something kind of
kooky and exotic that happens
like she becomes a Red Lantern or
becomes the Supergirl who last then
people are really interested right and a
lot of that's routed back to the fact
that in during the crisis on if it at
her story she was more powerful than
Superman right it was one of those
things that DC had kind of hit on
periodically for a while and then
basically confirmed during the crisis
story but this basically picks up with
her kind of looking around after she's
become the Supergirl who lasts and then
just sort of kind of taking on this
dance of like she's truly gonna fix the
world and she's truly gonna make the
world a better place now here's the
thing Jody Hauser's writing sometimes is
really really good and other times it's
kind of like I'm not really sure where
she's going with this but I do love what
she's doing here right because when it
comes to the various Kryptonians that
exist in DC Comics they always pull
their punches right we seen that happen
multiple times and it's been confirmed
multiple times over the course of DC
Comics that Superman pulls his punches
that if we saw Superman fight like
outright with all the strength that he
that he potentially has he could
potentially destroy the world right the
cool thing about this is that her
showing up and basically doing things
like rescuing a bus and so on and so
forth one of the things that you kind of
notice here is that she's kind of become
the darker version of herself not really
evil but almost really just kind of like
like obsessed with herself and so far as
like I'm the most important thing ever
and this manifests in the form of like
yes this bus is saved but instead of
like tending to the passengers and doing
what we would expect you to do which is
say is anybody okay is everybody alright
instead she's just like you're welcome
I've done a fine job and she like pat
yourself on the back and then goes about
her business and does her thing and
that's the kind of crazy situation is
because she immediately goes after the
bus driver right and the response here
is like these kids almost died and it
was all it was it was almost because of
you but it was if there's no questions
of like what happened here you know did
a tire blowout like dude like were you
drinking on the job but none of those
questions were asked is immediately the
assumption that like this guy screwed up
and like he now has to pay the price
right it's a very heavy-handed approach
but it's almost kind of a criticism of
like I know what's right 100% of the
time I kind of adopted that mentality
was it Philip DeFranco said why be
informed when you have your opinion it's
that kind of concept sort of thrown into
the comic insofar as she's just sort of
you know she's carried away with herself
now the good thing about this is that
Jodie Howser strikes a balance it be
very very easy to kind of go down like
the hardcore political scene but we get
just enough to works like okay so she's
basically become super arrogant and
super self-obsessed
but not so much where it's like all
right now I'm reading a political
message if it's done right
messages can be amazing we're a really
good example of that God loves man kills
if it's not really good well then you
basically get the first two years of
Marvel after all-new all-different so
yeah the cool thing about this is that
of course Superman shows up here and
this is where things begin to shift
because again for anybody who'd been
reading Supergirl for any real measure
of time the first thing they'll tell you
is that during the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths she was the last one
standing right all the versions of
Superman nicholae superboy-prime all
those guys had fallen and she was the
only one left who was powerful enough to
do really any kind of any kind of damage
or really even stand a chance against
the anti-monitor now she didn't save
everything right that all basically came
down to the specter but at the end of
the day she basically outlasted
everybody else and people kind of look
to that as the perspective of she's
stronger than Superman when you take
that and you couple it with a lot of the
things we've seen confirmed along the
way between the time that she reappeared
after after crisis on Infinite Earths
going into like new 52 and in DC
Universe rebirth and that kind of a
thing that she's just this really heavy
hitter and that's kind of what goes on
here is because she basically tells
Superman but you're a half-measure
right like you could fix the world you
could punish the criminals like you
could go to all these people who are
committing all these crimes and say
you're done now and the response of
Superman is but that's not why I'm here
and that's the beauty behind the
character of Superman right it's like
it's why Superman and Batman are such
incredibly amazing superheroes is
because what you end up having here is a
scenario or Superman's like yeah I mean
I could do that
right but if he did he'd become no
different than like the crime syndicate
from earth 3 he would bend the world to
his whim right it would be injustice
Superman we've seen that play out now
ultimately it's this idea that like
super her Supergirl kind of looks at him
as a guy who pulls his punches and the
result is that she absolutely thrashes
Superman now she doesn't beat him within
an inch of his life or anything like
that but it's made clear in no uncertain
terms that she's not pulling punches and
she chose to she could absolutely pummel
him and that's kind of a big moment here
it's a pretty significant thing right
because it really kind of ties in to the
historical aspect of Lee scene with her
character that she's more powerful than
Superman and so after he basically ends
up falling at the hands of Supergirl
then you have Batman who shows up and
this is a really this is really like
shady moment here right like you're
Supergirl being like shady as hell
because like she makes this comment to
him you know where he's like you know
she's like I'm not one of your teenagers
you can control how many of those kids
have you gotten killed and it's like
man like you that minutes cutting deep
drawn blood son that's pretty brutal but
Batman basically calls it for what it is
you're an impatient child right like
you're an impatient child with no
patience who's basically been given
these godlike powers and doesn't know
how to control them Superman sees you as
his cousin and that's nice and that's
cute I see you for what you are a danger
in a threat no one knows what direction
you're gonna go in if you're gonna snap
in just a story everybody and to a
degree that's kind of true but Superman
has had decades to prove himself to show
what he is and what he's about Supergirl
is still relatively new on the scene
she's not brand new like she didn't show
up in like three years ago or anything
like that but she certainly hasn't had
as much time to earn the trust of Batman
in the way that Superman has and even
with Superman it took a long long time
imn doesn't really trust anybody and so
as a result of that
Supergirl basically immediately targets
targets banished she takes out the
batwing sends that flying down to the
ground rips the door off and is like
still hiding behind your toys you know
what that reminds me of I know how many
of you guys remember it but it reminds
me of original sin right when basically
there was this this story where you
ended up finding out that that Bruce
Banner believed that Tony Stark was the
one responsible for him becoming the
Incredible Hulk in the first place
actually the Hulk manifest it kind of
goes in this warpath and like Iron Man
is just like fleeing for his life right
he's just like jumping from armor to
armor and that eventually gives his
hands on the on the Hulkbuster armor and
The Incredible Hulk comes walking into
the room and he's like always the
optimist Tony as if you really had a
chance with that suit of armor anyway
and then basically crushes the armor
around Iron Man brothers one of the
coolest moments ever we cover that in
original sin and you'll find that here
on the channel I think it's actually I'm
never recovered it individually or if we
covered it as part of the whole event
but you'll find that in the in the full
story that you'll find out in the
description but it's kind of a cool
little thing because Batman's response
is like yeah I don't trust you like I
don't know who you are like you're
you're just some kind of unknown thing
that's out there and her response is
like I could kill you if I wanted to but
I'm not because he won't let me of
course her speaking about the Batman who
lost he has his own plan for you and so
as a result she basically dismisses him
throws him away Superman rescues him and
then she takes off and it's kind of a
cool moment there because what this does
is it basically branches off into her
own individual comic right it kind of
continues on along the Supergirl plot
threads and will probably ultimately
wrap back around into the actual Batman
vs Superman line of stories at the
moment but it's a great little thing
here because what you get is essentially
this ridiculously just not really even
over
Howard so much as Supergirl in her raw
form when she's not pulling any punches
when she's not holding back and when she
really is taking on Batman to Superman
with the full length of her abilities
the only reason why she didn't kill
these guys is because she chose not to
because I would submit here that if
Supergirl so wanted to choose is she so
it so chose to do it she could kill
Superman
it wouldn't be an easy thing right she's
not gonna like punch him in the punch
him in the head and like shake his brain
and kill him right it's not gonna go
down that fast but she could beat him to
death and they'd be kind of a cool thing
like it'd be interesting to see like
this knock-down drag-out fight between
Supergirl and Superman in terms of who
would actually win here I'm kind of
curious okay so we are picking up with
the conclusion of Batman to Superman
number five and for those the guys who
have been following along with this you
guys are aware that what's been going on
here is the Batman who last kind of had
this grand plan right this could this
great big huge grand scheme and the idea
is that it were originated really
arriving on earth during the events of
the Dark Knights metal storyline now
some people have asked and I'd say this
in the comments some people had thought
the Batman who laughs had been killed
during the events of Dark Knight's metal
and the reality is that he hadn't right
the Batman who laughs actually just kind
of skirted around a little bit he was
part of the of the immortal men I think
it was for a little while although
nothing really significant was done with
him I think he just kind of appeared
like once in the first issue it wasn't
really until we got to the Batman story
you know that we basically saw you know
the this whole depiction of the Batman
who last planned but the idea is that
this plan has really been going on for
quite some time and so the indication
here is that the actions of Barbados and
all those guys during Dark Knight's
medal what's really more of something
they were doing and the Batman who last
was forming his own scheme along the way
but what he had done at least what we
knew about him is that in his own
universe when he had destroyed all the
various superheroes including the
Justice League and Superman and so on
and so forth that what he had intended
to do who was to basically repurpose the
the watchtower that the Justice League
Watchtower in his own universe so that
he could basically spread his influence
throughout any world that he arrives in
and that's what he's been doing here
right the whole idea was to basically
create a circumstance whereby the entire
Kryptonian system can be manipulated by
Jaime Reyes due to his abilities happen
to technology and then with the other
members of the infected with Jim Gordon
and those various characters they could
essentially open a portal to the dark
multiverse or to the universe of the
Batman who lost and then bring the
Justice League Watchtower through and
infect the entire earth in one fell
swoop that's really what he's been
shooting to do the entire time and at
the end of the last issue they succeeded
in pulling the
watchtower through now remember the
Batman who lost is currently held in
prison below the Hall of Justice
and he's been there since the Batman
story right even when this story first
picked up he's been there the entire
time but one of the things that goes on
is that the infection that he's
basically spread to Supergirl to Donna
Troy to Hawkman in these various
characters is that it allows him to
communicate with them on a frequency
that only they can hear presumably this
was developed by the Batman who last in
order to ensure the Superman couldn't
overhear but it's kind of funny here
because when this goes down Batman is
Superman still play their roles and in
fact Williamson does a really good job
of explained to us why it is they do
what they do and how they're functioning
this way but what they end up doing is
Superman initially tries to talk them
down now the reality of this is that on
the surface they seem too far gone where
they seem too far to be able to talk
back into reason that's just not really
the case anymore instead it's just kind
of like these guys are screwed and like
there's no way to get them back this
kind of the indication that's put on
here but the reality is that where some
of the of the the bugs and the various
organisms that exist inside Superman's
Fortress of Solitude are basically
brought into this location at the end of
the day they're able to kind of offer
some measure of resistance but the main
focus is the watchtower itself now of
course Superman ends up traveling to the
watchtower and Batman's basically facing
off against a couple forces along the
way the problem with this and this is
where things really get hairy is that
when Superman actually enters the
watchtower then he sees the full gravity
of what's going on the fact that the
entire Justice League from the Batman
who lasts universe has been killed and
then he turns around and of course he
sees the bodies of himself as well as
Lois Lane and Jonathan Kent now this is
where things get really screwed up right
because if you guys recall during the
origin story of the Batman who last one
of the things that he had done is what
the Joker had died and ultimately Bruce
Wayne ingested the you know the super
potent toxin that turned him into the
Batman who lasts that when he had
basically traveled and kind of brought
Superman in tricked him into being their
dad Superman and Jonathan were exposed
to black kryptonite which basically
twisted them up screwed them up and they
ended up to being the ones to kill Lois
Lane presumably beating her to death and
then they themselves seemed a kid
succumb to kryptonite now I don't think
it's explicitly stated that they ended
up dying from black kryptonite exposure
but at this point I don't know what else
would have killed them and so as a
result of that it's really cool because
then Shazam and Supergirl show up on the
scene and you'll get to see something
that you don't really get to see all
that often where Shazam sort of taught
Superman you know it says all yeah man
that happened you know I guess you were
just too weak in your universe and kind
of given a hard time making fun of them
basically you know calling empathetic
and and so on and so forth and even more
Supergirl joins in it says yeah like I'm
sorry about your loss you know even if
it is your family from another world but
this basically just shows how outmatched
you are that you would be happier if you
joined us different things like that
Superman flips that he absolutely lashes
out and again you don't get to see that
now you don't get to see this very often
but it is cool to see when it does
happen because Supergirl is totally
taken by surprise she's like holy crap I
don't even know this was coming now this
is one of those things that fans really
point to when they talk about the
strength differences between Superman
and Supergirl because traditionally you
know like one of the things we mentioned
in the previous video is that
historically super girls always been
shown to be stronger and more powerful
than Superman but a lot of you guys also
made a really really good point when
what you said was that oftentimes at the
same time to kind of accompany that
Supergirl is usually shown to be more
reckless and so because of that she
doesn't really hold back in the same way
Superman does and so the indication of
the Superman could actually be you know
and it seems to be possibly more
powerful than Supergirl he just holds
back his strength a lot more and it kind
of makes sense right you know Lex Luthor
or Superman get into a knock-down
drag-out fight and he just punches Lex
Luthor with all his strength or he's
gonna punch him into oblivion falcon
punch but that's basically what it's
gonna end up turning into you know just
punching the absolute hell out of him
and so because that sue man usually
holds back but in this instance he
doesn't really have to because both
Supergirl and Shazam can take it the
other part of this is very quick
thinking on his behalf right Shazam
trying to call down his Thunder too
messed up me out of the way it all
Tamilians up hitting Supergirl
it's cool to see these small little
moments go down but Superman is highly
pissed off and because of that is one of
these things where he's at a precipice
where he could snap and that's really
what the Batman who laughs has been
looking for to push Superman to a
position where he can snap right where
he can break because if he can break
that he could be recreated but he could
be put back together in a different way
presumably falling down that that darker
path now for Batman himself facing off
against Jaime Reyes of course it's
Batman right so he's always quick
thinking on the spot and so what he does
is he looks at hi me and he says
technically your scarab can't really be
infected but you can which means if
you're infected your scarabs not so
literally reaching in to Jaime yanking
the Scarab off and putting it on himself
basically he has all the powers of the
Blue Beetle now but it does allow him to
basically take that control of the of
the fortress of solitude which Jaime
Reyes has been controlling this entire
time and so from there he
ends up basically temporarily knocking
out Commissioner Gordon and then starts
talking to Superman and this is where
Williamson basically makes this really
really good point in terms of why they
don't fall down the path of becoming bad
guys because Batman starts to basically
speak with Superman and saying look I
get that you're angry and so as a result
of that madman kind of talks him down
this is look you've got a chill you've
got to relax if we end up becoming like
the villains that we're facing will be
better villains than they ever were the
other part of this and the reason why
these stories work so well is because
Batman basically makes this statement
right Superman always told that man that
you always worry too much for the
response of Batman is I never really
worried like I've never really worried
about things because I trust you and
that's a very important thing right
because what it shows is that Batman
recognizes the strength of Superman not
in so far theirs to make him punch
really hard and fly fast those are
things that that Batman of course
recognizes but is the strength of
Superman's character is the fact that
Superman is not so easily corrupted and
again with the Batman who lasts universe
is only the Batman who lasts basically
talks Superman into killing his family
and he was just easily manipulated they
literally had to use kryptonite in order
to turn Superman in that way right so
Superman's almost as incorruptible thing
that's the only entire nature behind
doomsday clock right Superman is
incorruptible he can't be screwed up
that way and justice kind of flies in
the face of that but some justice it's
different you know it's it's different
it's not the same thing and so as a
result that of course the the watchtower
of the Batman who lost is basically
pushed into the Sun and destroyed and
then in turn the response of Batman of
Superman is to talk to Commissioner
Gordon and that's the important thing to
bear in mind here is that when Batman
was talking to Superman and essentially
talking him down what he told him is you
have to let Supergirl in Shazam go
because you chasing after them is a
distraction that's basically what that
is don't let them distract you in that
way let them go off and do their thing
we have to destroy this watchtower but
when they're talking to Commissioner
Gordon is basically saying hey look
there's a way to bring you guys back
we'll figure out what it is
we'll turn everybody back to the way
they were so if you really believe this
is a permanent thing and you somehow
officially one then please understand
that's not the case and that's what he
chimes in and says but where do you
think your friends are going though and
of course that's we end up realizing
that in reality the Batman who lost kind
of saw this coming now again that's
where things sort of wear thin and
that's why I say the nature of Batman
really kind of wears thin right because
if you take everything that Batman does
and you apply it to a different
character then suddenly you start to
realize how redundant Batman is and it's
one of these things where it's like well
the Batman who lasts always saw this
coming he had this all
the entire time and so because of that
he was able to overcome whatever plan
Batman hat is one of those funny things
you know Batman does the exact same
thing he's written the exact same way
Batman is always like he always comes
out on top and that you're basically
seeing the nature of Batman thrown onto
a different character so I would submit
if what's going on with the Batman who
last really kind of bores you imagine
what it's like reading Batman all the
time it's pretty much the exact same
thing the difference is that his tore
his stories are just told differently
but it's kind of it's kind of cool here
because when they get down there of
course what the end of realizing is they
were played the entire time that this
entire scheme was never expected to
succeed this scheme had like the
satellite being pulled through and all
the kind of stuff there was no
expectation it was actually going to
work right because if it was why leave
it to some group like the secret six
which could easily and most likely be
overtaken by Batman and Superman
so the whole purpose behind what it was
about and who laughed wanted to do it
was essentially instigate this entire
circumstance where it looked like things
were going to pop off Batman to Superman
we're going to respond they were gonna
get into a great big huge fight and
knowing how things were going to go down
they were going to have to basically let
some of the members escape and do
whatever it is they were going to do in
order to stop the watchtower from
basically transforming the entire world
into a world of people who laugh and so
in doing that it left the door open for
Shazam and Supergirl to take off and to
basically free the Batman who lost and
so now he's kind of out of his cell and
back into things again so what this does
is it basically you know really forces
Batman and Superman to come to the
realization that keeping everything that
was going on to themselves and certainly
not bringing in Wonder Woman who's part
of the Trinity was the wrong mistake to
make and of course she's gonna be pissed
but everything else that goes on with
the Batman who lost is actually followed
in in the Batman who lasts and the
infected you're the villain he'll arisen
right so it follows their own individual
escapades over there in my mind the
story's cool but the whole concept with
a Batman who laughs is kind of starting
to wear thin and it's really just kind
of the same thing all the time right
like you know there's a circumstance
that unfolds and somehow the Batman who
laughs was all worried he was always
able to prepare for a circumstance that
he didn't know was coming by it's like
Batman you know Batman prepares for
things even if he doesn't know what's
going to happen right so keep of hair is
fur for unknown factors which seem
impossible but when you're Batman or the
Batman who laughs you have the power of
plot armor without being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come as explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port you guys
want to see my uncensored videos my vs.
videos and all my early access videos
make sure you guys go over to patreon
calm
comments explained and if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace we've got some new patrons in our
top tiers over on patreon.com slash
comments explained I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B as well as Steven Z
Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as well as
Genesis 916 as always we just usually
keep the last name - an initial it helps
you guys to maintain your anonymity some
of you guys are expressed concerned
about having like your first and last
name thrown out there for the world to
see I do not blame you for you guys who
have joined up as part of our patreon
tiers that are eligible for Rob port
honor guard rings those whose rings have
been sent out you should already have
them if you're a new person who just
joined up and you've been part of this -
here for a month your ring will be
mailed out to you so I want to say thank
you guys for being patrons
[Music]